qu'est ce que vous faites là je vais
vous aider je suis sûr que vous a piégé
racontez moi ce qui s'est passé
mr
l'expliquent ce que tu faisais là bas
n'était pas censé travailler
dans cette posture l'équipe
ya pas de nous deux qui tienne on n'est
pas équipiers c'est dommage que je
trouve qu'on compense bien les défauts
de l'autre
ah ouais j'ai quoi comme défaut
vrai et ce matin il miaule est encore
notre ville est malade
elle est dévoré lentement par la
corruption l'avidité et l'absence de
lois et je ne m'arrêterai pas avant
d'avoir extrait le pull de l'appeler
vous pensez que je vais trop loin
tu fous c'est ce que tu voulais
rendre le monde meilleur
vous savez combien de gens sont morts
et combien vont mourir encore
[Musique]